but when epstein
killed himself and i believed he killed
himself you do believe he killed himself
yeah i can set that out at great length
um
but i won't because with two hours uh
pretty much already i've said it out
briefly okay
no um there's a friend of mine called
chris atkins who's written a very funny
book
called a bit of a stretch and he was a
former
panorama producer freelance who ended up
um an attack scam and got done by the
british tax man and went to prison
sentence for five years and spent nine
months in wandsworth which is a terrible
nick
in london routinely
sex offenders and worst of all
pedophiles
were abused in prison and according to
his own personal observation
prison officers didn't bother check up
on pedophiles
because they wanted them to die
so but my friend chris it's a british
prison not an american prison but this
is not a conspiracy theory
this is observed experience
of prison culture a convicted pedophile
like jeffrey epstein
back in again back in again for
greater and better charges
of pedophilia is going to have a
horrible time in prison
from everybody including the prison
guards
so i think he very likely that they
didn't bother check on them
that they didn't care i think that
epstein was a clever and manipulative
man
but also he realized he'd run out of
road and there was no good defense for
what he'd done
and therefore he was looking at life and
this was a way of saying [ __ ] you
and he was that kind of guy who would do
that
thirdly i would say that there is a um
there was a pathologist hired by
jeffrey epstein's brother who i think is
called dr baden who went on fox
to say that his uh
there's a bone there called hyoid bone
was broken
and that is evidence of murder
not suicide so
being a good reporter i checked this
with an american pathologist
and it's in the podcast who set
out the evidence by by going through
something like 168
definite suicides by hanging
and found that two-thirds of the cases
the higher
bone was broken really
yes really and
the older the the um
the deceased the more likely the higher
bone would be broken
so when i say that jeffrey epstein
killed himself i'm not arguing with
donald trump for a gag
i'm setting out the the known
evidence which is number one
there is a culture inside prisons in
britain and the united states and around
the world that hates pedophiles
the prison guards should have been
checking on him
they didn't because they didn't [ __ ]
care
number two chris says
that the prisoner estate in british
prisons and american prisons
is always rubbish the cctv cameras
didn't work
that's normal nothing works in prison
because when you complain nobody gives a
[ __ ] because you're a prisoner
number three the physiological evidence
that points to murder
is rubbish the physiological evidence
either
sorry the pathological evidence points
to suicide
not murder and the advance
of the suicide version
is not supported by science
if you doubt me listen to my podcast
hunting
final question
if you were to be able to sit down with
elaine g-lane right now
what would you ask her my question would
be
did robert maxwell [ __ ] you up
why that question did her father
cause her to be where she is now
because he was an abusive personality
there's there's a uh you can you don't
have to go
with this woman other than barry goes
one of her brothers ian maxwell said
that when he heard
that his father had died
he felt both fear of what
what to do next but also a sense of
exhilaration
that this alpha male had gone from his
life so you can just
use that to say did he
so it's possible i don't know where it
goes this court case
i'm fascinated to watch it um if i can
i'll try and get to new york um
but um we'll see
the
there's i'm sorry i'm going on pointless
oh no i'm going on for a reason because
this is
um this troubles me i don't know what's
going to happen
[Music]
at the moment there is
it seems three witnesses to abuse
and the charges relate primarily to 1994
to 1997.
so the stuff we all know about all the
stuff for example that's in the netflix
documentary
virginia robert shufree she meets them
in 2000 she meets prince andrew in 2001.
conveniently not a part of her charges
not in the charges now
conveniently is a loaded adverb and one
should always avoid
loaded adverbs okay noted
they may have done that the feds may
have done it is because they don't
want to put virginia robert shufrae
in the witness box unless she gets
something wrong
which is not to say that she's right
fundamentally
but abuse victims often
make poor witnesses that's an argument
that's been put to me
i don't know my judgment about what she
says about prince andrew and her
i think um that
um well prince andrew can't explain the
photograph
virginia roberts cam i think regina
roberts is telling the truth
but for whatever reason the feds aren't
going there
there's a qualification for this which
is they're going there
on the um they've also charged
jalan with perjury and it's possible
they can take
some of the perjury stuff and chuck it
but that's
they're not they're being careful about
the timeline because i think they want a
conviction
had epstein still been alive
jalen's route
to a soft sentence would have been
giving the dirt on jeffrey epstein
[Music]
once he died i think he killed himself
then that possibility
for a plea that the value of the police
of the feds has gone
so what she's offering what she could do
is say i was a victim of jeffrey epstein
i was also a victim of my father and i'm
terribly sorry
but i was not in the sound mind when i
did this
her problem with that is
that she
should have said that the moment jeffrey
epstein
died if i was her
i would have done it the second he died
and i would
give him a press conference saying
it's the first time i can talk about
this but i feel desperately sorry for
the victims
virginia roberts included but i got this
entirely wrong because i was manipulated
by this man and
only now but he's dead that i can talk
about this
instead she disappeared
that's a big problem for her
as i said she denies any wrongdoing
she denies all the charges against her
and
fair fair i believe passionately in the
rule of law and i believe in innocence
or proven guilty so we're gonna have to
wait and see
what she says and what the defense is um
i feel sorry for her i do but it doesn't
mean
i don't think um i think the evidence
against her is damning
um i'm fascinated as i said to see
what's going to happen
but i do feel sorry for her she's in a
horrible place
in our awful prison and
this horrible stuff from her pastors
coming back to her
at the same time i also feel desperately
sorry for the victims
virginia robert shufrey is the most
famous
i believe what she says i do um and i
think
people are responsible for their actions
anyway
we have to um we'll see how it plays
john i can't thank you enough for doing
this man i really appreciate it i'm a
huge fan of your work